alors à votre avis dans cette cabine à
bluff qu'y at il je vais tout de suite
allé regarder et je vais vous dire ce
que je vois est ce qu'il y a stéphane
tracera c'est à dire c'est comme
stéphane plaza mais c'est un mec qui lui
a manqué ses trois dernières fiches de
paye et trouve pas d'appart ou est ce
qu'il y a derrière le rideau
jackie et michel yahiel des fans
malfrats n'ont stéphanois sera jacques
et michel attention sur un canapé rouge
[Musique]
alors à votre avis ciel drucker qu'y
at-il à ouennougha qu'il s'est chargé
qui me suivait celle qui a dit stéphane
ratera au début moi c'est jean miché
bascharage couet jackie et michel c'est
une seule personne donc ça m'étonnerait
que mais pourquoi c'est une seule
personne jacques et michel ajustements a
peut-être avoir jacques et michel et
bien les séries il y à ce soir avec nous
jacqueline bisset michel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jeanne d'arc est avec nous
jacques et michel jacques sion d'une
frappe lenovo
merci merci d'être allé chez merci